I mean obviously you just got off stage
to receive a huge honour from Africa and
you're just experiencing something that
we're all as a community just so proud
of before with Black Panther let me talk
to me about now getting an Oscar
nomination for Black Panther and just
creating this historic story that is
going to continue oh that's a lot I
think uh smooch is trying to make the
movie as best as we could you know and
it's a habit embrace like it like it has
me has been incredible in it for people
to still be thinking about it and
talking to part of it you know
especially a year after it came out it's
a deep it's a deep honor man it doesn't
always happen
Hartsfield portion what kind of forever
really means what kind of forever when
it comes to the film industry and just
as a whole but just talk to me up how
would you react if you won Best Picture
at the Oscars Oh to be honest I'll try
not to think about that you know it's
like in one day at a time and for me
like the honor is being able to just
focus on the work you know I mean like
all that all the other stuff is really
it's really fun to other people don't
worry about something honest you know
like I'm so happy for the cash I'm happy
for everybody involved with the film you
know I'm happy for everybody who's
received any type of recognition but I
was a close and personal and I saw how
hard everybody worked you know and then
image so I'm just honored at the
audience and braces